hey guys it's Joanna here I'm so excited
because this flat dolly meal prep is a
collaboration with Lorraine from baking
that gym addict
Lorraine it's such a bubbly person and I
consider her as the queen of meal
prepping her YouTube channel has lots of
step-by-step meal prepping videos which
you can follow and learn you have to
check her out and be sure to subscribe
to a YouTube channel so no matter how
much time you dedicate to exercising if
you do not much over when you eat you
will still have belly fat your meals are
extremely important for you to achieve
your fitness goals so in order to
succeed we got to plan and prep ahead so
I'll be sharing the meals from Monday to
wednesday and hop on to Lauren's channel
to get the full meals for Thursday to
Saturday I want you to follow my meal
prep ideas step a picture of a meal
prepping process and share it with other
kidneys on the pump up app download the
app stay inspired join the community and
follow me at Curacao
so I've challenged myself to create this
meal plan which is suitable for vegan
requires minimal cooking in fact you
only be cooking one meal time efficient
I've kept all these meals under ninety
minutes we'll be using really simple
ingredients which are widely available
and of course we will only be using real
foods which are high in nutritional
values so let's get started for
breakfast it has to be the hearty
overnight oatmeal you can't have an easy
or healthy breakfast than this it is so
simple all you have to do is combine
your selected ingredients place them in
a jar seal and refrigerate overnight so
I've made three different variations for
each day for Monday it's chocolate
banana overnight oatmeal the ingredients
are half a cup of oats 1/2 a cup of
unsweetened so
or any other milk of your choice one
medium ripe banana mashed
one tablespoon of pure cocoa powder and
1 teaspoon of chia seeds for Tuesday
let's have sweet fruity overnight
oatmeal half a cup of oats 1/2 a cup of
unsweetened soy milk half a cup of
pineapple diced and 2 tablespoons of
pure fruit gel of your choice and for
Wednesday its granola overnight oats 1/2
a cup of oats 1/2 a cup of unsweetened
soy milk again any other milk of your
choice 1 tablespoon of goji berries 2
tablespoons of cranberries and 1
tablespoon of sunflower seeds breakfast
is ready in less than 10 minutes now
let's move on to lunch so assuming that
most of us will not be at home for lunch
I've opted for vegan mashed chickpeas
sandwich so practice to work or school
oh so yummy the ingredients you need are
one can of chickpeas rinsed and drained
3/4 cup of carrots chopped into cubes
cut a cup of onions finely diced 2
tablespoons of sunflower seeds 1
tablespoon of fresh parsley roughly
chopped juice from half a lemon one
teaspoon of smoked paprika 1 teaspoon of
olive oil salt and pepper to taste let
us lift as much as you like and 6 medium
bread slices no cooking is required for
this recipe in a large bowl roughly mesh
chickpeas with a fork or potato masher
add the remaining ingredients carrots
onions sunflower seeds parsley lemon
juice smoked paprika olive oil and
season with salt and pepper combine well
time to pack my lunch I like to pack the
sandwich feeling separate from the bread
slices and lettuce leaves to protect
myself which from going salty and to
keep it fresh each serving with two
medium grit slices contain about 323
calories what I'll do is assemble by
some region in the morning and bring it
out with me all you can assemble it at
work or school now let's move on and
prep dinner I do like my Asian cuisines
so for dinner I'm going to introduce you
to these delicious scrambled tofu
pineapple fried rice fried rice is
probably the easiest meal you can put
together because you just can't go wrong
with it you can pretty much throw and
mix any ingredients in and it will still
taste yummy so for my fried rice the
ingredients I've used are one block of
fun tofu mashed one and a half cups of
wealth of brown rice cooked and cool
left over rice is perfect for this half
a cup of carrots finely sliced 150 gram
of broccoli chopped 1 cup of pedicle
chunks 1 large red bell pepper diced
into cubes 3 garlic cloves minced 1
medium stock of spring onion sliced 1
tbsp of red chilli finely sliced quarter
cup of cashew nuts 1 tbsp of sesame oil
1 tbsp of soy sauce and juice from one
lime in a pan heat have a tablespoon of
sesame oil over medium-high heat stir in
the tofu and cook for 4 to 5 minutes and
the tofu is slightly Brown remove from
heat and set aside add the remaining
half a tablespoon of sesame oil add
garlic and Lana stir-fry
about one minute until golden-brown and
fragrance stir in the carrot and
broccoli cook for 3 to 4 minutes and two
vegetables are slightly tender even the
vegetables are too dry add a dash of
water then mix in bell pepper pineapple
chunks and cashew nuts continue to cook
for another three to four minutes
and developers are slightly caramelized
on the edges and cashew nuts are
slightly Brown stir in the rice soy
sauce and lime juice cook for another
three to four minutes until rice is
heated through and our ingredients are
well combined finally add the scrambled
tofu spring onion and red chili cook
very quickly for another one to two
minutes remove from heat and allow the
rice to cool down once the rice has
cooled down I'll pack them evenly into
three containers for my three days
dinner done tofu is a perfect egg
substitute for vegans you're getting
lots of colorful vegetables in the dish
balanced with sweet pineapple and subtle
heat from the red chili so yummy and
healthy inches serving has about three
hundred and seventy six point five
calories so all lemon meals are ready in
less than an hour I'll pet them install
them in the fridge for up to three days
as for snacks again think it's simple I
like to have one liquid snack and one
snack on the go when I'm out so for my
mid-morning snack it has to be mango
green smoothie I'll start by measuring
almost smoothie ingredients 1 cup of
baby spinach one cup of diced mango one
cup of sliced banana and 1 tbsp of goji
berry
this is for one serving once that's done
pack all the ingredients into three
super bags and Su place the bags into
the freezer and when I'm ready to have
my morning smoothie all I have to do is
add one cup of water and blend away so
you can mix and match any fruits or
vegetables to your liking be sure to
watch my how to make the perfect green
smoothie video for step-by-step guidance
as for my snake on the go it is just a
simple trail mix so measure it to a
quarter cup and the kenri will range
from 140 to about 170 calories so my to
mix combinations our dried cranberries
cashew nuts goji berries and sunflower
seeds pack into three small stack
containers and I'll bring this out with
me it is important to bring a small
healthy snack out with you
whether it's a piece of fruit trail mix
or energy bar so that if you do feel
peckish you will have a healthy snack to
turn to this vegan flat belly meal prep
averages at about 1,500 calories and I
will also give myself about 150 extra
calorie allowance especially on my
workout days so depending on your
activity level and also your body
measurements you will have to adjust the
calories accordingly remember to not be
too obsessed over calorie counting these
values are meant to act as a guideline
for you to understand portion control
and also to avoid overeating in the end
the most important is to eat real food
food closest to its natural state and
minimally processed so use this meal
plan as a guideline for your meals on
monday to wednesday and hop on to
lawrence channel to get the full meals
for Thursday to Saturday and on Sunday
you can choose to make your favorite
healthy meals and treat yourself to one
reward meal so these are my favorite
simple dish
which I don't mind repeating on a
regular basis for me to maintain a
healthy weight Pig and match your
favorite ingredients prep and letterhead
and I trust you will achieve your
fitness goal are the best